of the council and members of the
present public i welcome you to this
meeting of the council
prior to this meeting all participants
have previously checked that they can be
heard
and seen and can see and hear other
members
it is vital that you can be heard and is
preferred that cameras are kept
on throughout the meeting to double
check this
and to introduce everyone who is present
at this remote meeting
i will kindly ask that i confirm your
attendant
and your role or job title when i say
your name
if you have a technical difficulty
during the meeting then please contact
one of the democratic services officers
on call who will attempt to assist you
i would ask all participants when you
are not speaking please
mute your microphone this minimizes
background noise and will help everyone
in listening to the proceedings
microphones must only be on if the
participant has been granted permission
to speak
to gain my permission to speak please
very briefly indicate on the chat
to the right side of the screen
and i will then make a note and go back
to you once the person speaking
before has finished please note this
meeting is being
live streamed for members of the public
except for any item of business
where exempt or confidential information
is considered
following an exclusion of the press and
public from moving
this meeting is also being recorded and
will be subsequently broadcast
on the internet with everyone present
please ensure that their mobile phones
are turned to silent
and they are not used to make or receive
phone calls while the meetings in
progress
do not turn your phone off as it will
make it harder for democratic services
to contact you should they need to
please also refrain from checking emails
or conducting other business
and ensure that you're in a quiet room
free from distractions for the duration
of the meeting
moving straight on uh councillors to
agenda item one
apologies for absence i have received
apologies from councillors paul moore
are there any other apologies this
evening
sorry sorry apologies uh just uh
noted apologies from councillor cup this
evening as well
sorry the cup yes also
chancellor linda potts their work
linda pops a council of whitehead okay
councillor whitehead
i have got that are there any other
apologies
chairman counselor dennis
chair can i just point out there are a
number of members and uh
mrs benedict who have still got their
microphones on
if they can mute them otherwise you get
a lot of feedback
this is true thank you very much indeed
counselor campbell yes
just to remind everyone please
would you switch your microphones off
unless i have asked you to speak
it is not possible for me to check
everyone but i'd ask for your
assistance in this matter uh
right now to a register
of attendees this evening
i shall move first of all to councillors
if you could indicate your presence this
evening
first of all councillor album
er here chair counselor aura
here councillor ashby
present chair councillor bailey
here chair councillor bambridge
[Music]
counselor braidwood
councillor he said his apologies
right apologies councillor campbell
here councillor coleman cook
here chair councillor christendom
councillor curry present chair
councillor day here chair
councillor dennis i believe we've
already had apologies
councillor dexter a present chairman
councillor duckworth
councillor everett i'm here chad
councillor parents present chair
councillor fellows yeah i'm here
council again here
councillor green
are you there councillor greene i'll
move on
councillor gregory here chair
councillor hart here che
councillor hopkinson here chair
councillor huxley
here chair thank you councillor keane
here chair councillor cup has apologies
counselor pat moore
here chair councillor paul moore i have
apologies
council oven done uh here check
councillor parson
councillor parsons he sent his apologies
to you
apologies councillor piper
here chair councillor stuart
here chip councillor potts
center apologizer that's right yeah
thank you for reminding me here
councilloraticum here councillor roth
here too councillor rogers
here chair councillor ropa
hey chair councillor roseki
president chairman councillor david
saunders
here chair councillor mae saunders
president chairman councillor scobee
here chairman councillor scott
councillor scott hi there councillor
scott
i'll move on he yeah i think he's uh
mobile he might have communication
issues
but he yeah i'd like him to speak for
himself if he could
he's just put it in the chat all right
excellent counselor shrub
here chair counselor taylor
councillor taylor
now i'll move on councillor tomlinson
here chairman councillor towning
president council whitehead i have
apologist for
councillor wing here
counselor right here chair
counselor yates here chair
i'll move on to officers please confirm
your job title
madeleine homer
sorry here chair chief executive thank
you
tim howes air chair uh director of
corporate governance
gavin waite here chair corporate
director of communities
tim willis here chair deputy chief
executive and section 151 officer
nick hughes
committee services manager charlotte
crowley
president shares the democratic services
officer charles hungway
i'm here at dson call
emily kennedy here they're so
also on call excellent i understand
there are several members of the public
in this meeting who will have an
opportunity
to introduce themselves when it is their
turn to speak
is there anyone in this meeting whose
name i have not read out
how's your chance no
right moving on
please note this meeting is being live
streamed for members of the public
except for any item of business where
exempt or confidential information is
given following
the exclusion of the present public from
the meeting
now having gone through all of that
moving on to agenda item one
i've had apologies for absence from
councillors cup
uh potts whitehead dennis
and is that
yes that's all i think isn't it agenda
item 2
minutes of the meeting held on the 9th
of july 2020.
i move that the minutes of the meeting
of the council held on june 9th of july
2020 be approved and signed as a correct
record
with the vice chairman please second the
second like mr chairman
excellent unless anyone objects the
minutes i will take them as
agreed
thank you agenda item three
announcements i do have an announcement
we are shortly to lose two popular
and well-known members of our staff
charlotte crowley from democratic
services
and emily kennedy well known from
licensing
i'm sure councillors would want to wish
them all the best with their future
careers
a general item for declarations of
interest are there any declarations of
interest this evening
i don't hear any and i see nothing on
the screen
i'll move on therefore to agenda item
five
petitions this evening the general item
five
council response the park avenue
broadstairs petition
for information only would members
please note an e-petition
containing 319 valid signatures
and a paper petition containing 455
valid signatures has been received by
the council
please note there will be an opportunity
for members to discuss this matter
further
under agenda item 8a which will be
coming up later this evening
i'm pleased to welcome mrs seuss on
behalf of mr tate
to take the meeting if you would like to
turn your microphone
on you have
up to three minutes to introduce the
petition
are you there mrs seuss would you like
to switch your microphone on
and then you will you'll be in a
position
to read to your petition
if you raise the screen at the bottom
you'll find a microphone that you can
release
to start speaking are you with us
mr hughes can you help us at this point
i believe mrs is with us okay there we
are excellent stuff
yes all right would you like to receive
mr zeus
you may can you may start
okay my name is amanda seuss on the
okay thank you for the opportunity
of introducing our petitions which have
been organized to bring the council's
attention
to the unwarranted devastation of an
area of
woodland at park avenue we believe the
council
gave permission for one tree to be
failed yet more than 40 were taken down
leaving a totally derelict landscape we
seek the council to use its powers to
have the area restored
to its pre-devastation situation with
the trees replaced like for like
and in the position of the felled trees
we also asked the council
to reaffirm its view that the area
should be retained
as an open space woodland and to take
action to deter
others from having total disregard for
the council's
permissions and the environment anger
annoyance
and frustration are felt by residents
and users
not only at the devastation but at the
manner it was done
a hand-delivered letter from the
landowner suggested
health and safety work to trees and the
contractors entered the site the next
day
leaving only a few trees standing at the
perimeter
councils and officers were contacted the
response
that it was being investigated yet
little enforcement action has
been seen over the last six months the
strong feeling of so many people
prompted five residents to form an
informal group
to make strong representation to the
council
more than 50 people have joined the
group which suggests the possibility of
such a group helping
to maintain the area and neighbouring
woodlands in good order much like
markets would
because of the lockdown it was necessary
to run an e-petition
which resulted in 319 signatures
as locked down is we decided to attempt
a paper petition
and after three days we had 455 new
signatures
confirmed as non-signatures of the
e-position
petition together there are an excess of
750 signatures
this should determine their progress
through the council
the woodland in question is part of a
large parcel of land
that was sold in 1931 with a covenant
that approximately 50 percent of the
land should be kept as open space
subsequent transfer of the part of the
land was seen
75 of the area being housing developed
this leaves an undevelopment area which
is now desecrated
which we now seek to retain as an open
space
the council stated that when making tree
preservation orders in
1985 and 2010 that the land
in view of its considerable immunity
value
it is therefore considered expedient to
take the necessary steps
to ensure its preservation trees are
such an important part of our existence
yes yet greatly neglected stats from
friends of the earth show that then it
has one of the largest sparsities of
trees in the county
country at 4.4 percent during the
coveted lockdown
period emphasis that has been placed
upon the well-being of people
and now mr susan i need to wind up now
can can combat several health issues
finally the count the council has
that's fine just finish off you're
winding up that's good thank you
okay finally okay finally the council
has declared a climate change
emergency and is pursuing a strategy
to improve our environment here we have
an example of the action of a developer
that takes no regard of that you can now
put this right by showing
that it understands the impact to our
environment and values it highly
on so many fronts the council could be
in a win-win situation here
please ensure that this environmental
devastation is not left unchallenged
and that the developer is pursued and
that you affirm to the local plan review
that the area
must be left as an open space for the
benefit of residents and council
taxpayers
well thank you very much indeed mrs zeus
very well delivered
in accordance with the council's
petition scheme the petition will be
referred to cabinet without debate for
report to the council
within three ordinary meetings thank you
very much indeed
i'm moving on now to agenda item 5b
council response to bigger bins in fact
this again for information only would
members please note an e-petition
containing
42 valid signatures had been received by
the council
unfortunately we've had no response from
the individual who created the petition
however in accordance with the council
petition scheme the petition will be
referred to cabinet
without debate for report to the council
within three ordinary meetings
therefore moving on to agenda item six
questions from the press and public
six questions have been received from
members of the republic in accordance
with council procedure
rule number 13 please note that only the
questioner
and respondent are permitted to speak on
the question
and if the questioner is not present at
this meeting
their question cannot be put but will be
replied to
in writing therefore we're moving on to
agenda item six
a question number one from a member of
the public regarding the coach house
i am pleased to introduce a question
from mrs
iris johnston mrs johnson has requested
that her question be read by an officer
i therefore call upon the committee
services manager
mr nick nicholas hughes
thank you chairman uh the question is as
follows
the lease on the coach house in
northbound park is due to end in 2021
after years of failure to reopen as a
museum
could the leader please confirm that the
building will not be relent to the
existing leaseholder
who has failed to comply with the
original agreement and
thank you very much indeed nick i call
upon councillor duckworth to respond
councillor duckworth are you there yes
uh thank you for your question iris the
relationship between the council
and one of its tenants is confidential
to the parties as well as being
commercially sensitive
it is not appropriate to breach that
confidentiality or publicly share
commercially sensitive information i'm
therefore not able to respond
however i do thank you for drawing my
attention to this issue and will pass on
your concerns to
the director of property thank you
thank you very much indeed councillor
duckworth general isom 6b
question number two from a member of the
public regarding destruction of woodland
infante
i am pleased to welcome mrs paula
benedict to the meeting
could the questioner please turn on
their microphone and state
the name of the cabinet member to whom
their question is to be put
and read out the exact wording of the
question that they have submitted to the
council
mrs benedict are you there hello
to a councillor rick everett what if any
significant deterrents
will the council use in future to
prevent landowners and developers
continued illegal destruction of open
spaces
and woodland infant
thank you very much indeed mr bennett i
call upon councillor everett
to respond thank you chair and um thank
you for the question
um the new local plan which we adopted
at our last council meeting and um
is now enforced contains a number of
policies that seek to protect and
enhance trees and woodland
particularly where development is
proposed these are policy sp 23
which states that development proposals
should demonstrate how they respect and
respond to the character
key sensitivities qualities and
guidelines of the relevant landscape
character areas
the landscape character assessment
supplementary planning document
which was adopted alongside the local
plan contains guidance
about how new development can be
incorporated into the wider landscape
including how existing features and new
planting can assist that process
policy sp 27 addresses the green
infrastructure network
and identifies ways in which development
can protect and contribute to that
network
policy sp 30 sets out requirements for
new development to make a positive
contribution to the conservation
enhancement and management of
biodiversity assets
resulting in a net gain for biodiversity
policy gio 6 refers to landscaping and
green
infrastructure in new developments and
policy qdo2
sets out how new development proposals
should address
existing landscape features the council
investigates any breaches of planning
control in relation to these policies
and will take enforcement action where
it is in the public interest
in addition to this existing groups of
trees or woodland
can where they are in conservation areas
or of particular community value
be protected by tree preservation orders
the council then has powers to enforce
their protection
including prosecution against
unauthorized removal under the planning
act
council officers often attend sites to
require a cessation of works to
protected trees
upon receiving complaints from the
public for areas of woodland not
protected
the council liaises with the forestry
commission if felling has occurred
as a licence may be required from the
commission
the council would also work with kent
police's wildlife liaison officer
who would pursue any illegal destruction
of protected species
under the wildlife and countryside act
thank you very much indeed councillor
everett
on to agenda item 6c question number
three from a member of the public
regarding a thanet street strategy
i'm pleased to welcome mr tate to the
meeting could the questioner please turn
on their microphone and state the name
the cabinet member to whom the question
is to be put
and read out the exact wording of the
question that they may be submitted to
counsel
mr tate are you there yes chairman thank
you
and my question will be again to a
councillor everett is
member responsible for trees my question
is
talented there's relatively few trees
with only 19 mentions in the local plan
so will the council prepare a tree
strategy
aimed at increasing tree canopy cover in
the district
maximizing the benefit that trees give
promoting biodiversity
conserving tree and woodland ecosystem
as many other councils have done
thank you very much indeed mr tate i
call upon councillor eric again to
respond
yes thank you chair and uh uh thank you
once again for the question
um i'm not sure that i'm the member
responsible for trees accepting
as leader perhaps i'm responsible for
everything i'm responsibly responsible
for planning
um so my response is that i'm pleased to
confirm the council
is preparing a fanta tree an outline
draft strategy has been discussed at the
climate emergency working party meeting
in july
and will be progressed forwards by a new
climate change officer
who started this week we're also
awaiting an update on the national tree
strategy for england
to help steer ours and i just add really
the the
i'm sure councillors across the country
across the council
do understand the importance of
improving the tree covering phanet
i'm grateful to the members of the
public and others who brought these
issues to our attention particularly the
issue in broad stairs
um i've already referred to the policies
that are in the local plan i don't see
any purpose in me reading you the list
of policies that i read to the previous
questioner
but certainly they're all relevant and i
can assure you that this is a matter
that we're taking very seriously
thank you thank you very much indeed
council everett of course you do realize
this leader you're taking responsibility
for everything aren't you
same side a agenda item 60 question
number four
from a member of the public regarding
the climate emergency
i'm pleased to introduce a question from
mrs shotham
mr schotten has requested that her
question is read
by an officer i therefore call once
again upon
mr nicholas hughes
thank you chairman uh the question is as
follows
the climate emergency is the biggest
threat to mankind
the council should be progressing and
implementing the climate change
sorry the climate emergency action plan
why is the council wasting time
and money on environmentally harmful
plans at the port
instead of investing in clean
technologies to help meet this challenge
thank you once again nick i call upon
councillor duckworth to respond
councillor duckworth are you there i am
thank you for the question
senate district council declares a
climate emergency on thursday 11th of
july 2019.
since then we have formed a working
party consisting of elected members from
across the political parties
to consult discuss and steer our
response to the climate and ecological
emergency
an action plan has been formulated to
capture what
work that is already underway alongside
opportunities and
ideas our new climate change officer
dr hannah scott started on first of
september
and she will be driving the council's
response to the climate emergency moving
forwards
coordinating and developing our action
plan further
we are linked with other councils across
the county through the kent resource
partnership
and the kent climate change network
taking national and county steer on the
approach
through the kent environment strategy
and other developing directives
we will monitor plans in relation to
developments and changes to legislation
as they happen
we are also planning to set up
opportunities in the coming months to
engage with the public
on our proposed activities the reference
in the question to plan
to plans at the port is understood to be
in relation to birth form 5 replacement
project
the existing aggregate birth earth form
five
at the port of ramsgate is at the end of
its operational life
there is no viable option to refurbish
or maintain the existing birth
a long-term contractual commitment with
a customer exists
such that the council must maintain an
operational birth or risk the
consequences of breaching the contract
agreement
a project has therefore been developed
to replace the birth
it is also also worth mentioning that
the requirement for an environmental
impact assessment as part of the marine
licensing process
was screened out by the marine
management organisation
thank you thank you very much indeed
councillor duckworth
agenda item 6e question number five from
a member of the public regarding
community woodland i'm pleased to
welcome miss mckenzie to the meeting
good the questioner please turn on their
microphone and state the name of the
cabinet member to whom their question is
be put
and read out the exact wording of the
question that they submitted to the
council
hi there mrs kenzie thank you chair
my question is to steve alban i'm
wondering whether i should have directed
it to rick everett
actually the 2006
adopted local plan set aside an
area of land roughly 21.7 hectares
behind twenties cottages on charlene
road extending to heartstown road
margate for community woodland
why has this land now been designated
for housing
with no planting having taken place in
the subsequent
14 years thank you
thank you very much indeed mr mckenzie
uh who's taking it is it once again you
counselor everett or is it councillor
orban
there is me chair excuse me sir well
done
thank you very much for the question
the site proposed for a community
woodland in the 2006 plan
is situated to the north of the housing
site allocated in the new local plan
it's not in fact the same site prior to
the 2006 plan there was a detailed
project developed
for planting of the community woodland
however during the process of developing
the scheme
the woodland grant scheme was amended
such that the project was not eligible
for funding
as a result the project was not
progressed at the time the site was put
into the local plan
as a potential project to be supported
thank you very much indeed councillor
everett agenda item 6f
question number six from a member of the
public regarding ramsgate port birth
four stroke five
i'm pleased to welcome miss austin to
the meeting could the questioner please
turn
on their microphone and state the name
the cabinet member to whom their
question is to be put
and read out the exact wording of the
question that they are submitting to the
council
mr hospital are you there i am thank you
chair
um my question i believe is to counselor
alban
uh it's about ram skateport i understand
ramsgate port both
four and five currently producing 400
tons of aggregate per
hour are to be replaced with a 3 000
tons per hour facility
could you please explain why this is
needed
what impact it will have on the
neighboring sssi
and why this has been characterized as a
like-for-like replacement
thank you thank you very much indeed
miss austin
i call once again on councillor everett
to respond thank you chair and
and thank you to ms austin for her
question um
i think there's a bit of confusion
really in the question the birth is not
currently
processing uh processing 400 tons of
aggregate per hour
uh vessels actually arrive vessel
arrivals on the birth occur
approximately
fortnightly in 2019 an average of 125
tons per day
was discharged by the birth the purpose
of the birth is to transfer
aggregate from a vessel to the shore the
berth itself
doesn't have any aggregate processing
ability
and obviously it's not in use all the
time so the actual capacity of it is not
particularly relevant to that the
existing conveyor on the berth however
has the capability of transferring 400
tons of aggregate per hour
while unloading a vessel the performance
specification for the replacement berth
requires that it has the capability of
safely accommodating the loads
from a 3000 ton per hour conveyor a
higher capacity conveyor
allows vessels to be unloaded faster
but this does not mean that the tonnage
of aggregate handled
will increase and obviously it's more
efficient for the company
if they can unload the aggregate faster
the council is not currently aware
of any plans by its customer aggregates
to increase the volume of aggregate
discharged
via the birth following completion of
the project
the replacement option chosen is the
most economical option for the 30-year
service life of the birth
it will be able to accommodate slightly
larger vessels
but the council is not aware of any
current proposals to bring larger
vessels
and this is about making the birth
viable over its service life
as new vessels come into service the
birth has not been designed as an
upgrade the opinion of the marine
management organization
is that the proposed project is screened
out of requiring an environmental
impact assessment this provides an
indication of the low level of
environmental risk
posed by the proposal thank you
thank you very much indeed counselor
everest uh that
concludes the agenda item for questions
from members of public
moving on to agenda item seven questions
from
members of the council six questions
this evening have been received from
members of the council
please note that the time allowed for
consideration of the questions from
members shall
not exceed 30 minutes without the leave
of the chair
and i'm feeling generous this evening
agenda item 7a
question number one from a member
regarding pontoons in ramsgate harbour
i call upon councillor wing councillor
wing are you there
thank you chair yes it's a straight
close question
and i think my question is for
councillor alban and i would like to
respond as well
will one of the two bam knuckle pontoons
presently mooring in ramsgate's
royal harbour be used to replace births
four and five
now i thank you very much energy
councillor wing is this councillor alban
or councilman
can i chair um if i can uh help clarify
the matter for councillor wing
and others who may be confused about
that i am the cabinet member for the
portland harbour
that's why i answer questions about the
cabinet about the portland harbour
council album is not the cabinet member
for the portland harbour i understand
that because he's the cabinet member for
operational services
that may not be clear to members but
that is what the that's what the um
portfolios are
so i deal with the portland harbour
thank you clarification
to give you your answer councillor wing
which i i suspect you already know the
answer yes
i do a contract has been awarded to the
contractor bam nut
limited for the replacement of the birth
the project will involve the reuse of
one of the two pontoons that are
currently moored in the royal harbour at
ramsgate
a yes would have been great could i
respond chair howard or counseling do
you have a supplementary question
i do i do given tdc
has been locked into a lease agreement
which does not end until 2054 with
brett's
and i believe the rent they pay
according to the lease of 2009 which is
the only copy i've been able to get a
hand off suggests that their rent is
less than 20k a year
2500 for the cement bachelor and 15 000
for that aggregate but there is rpi to
be added
on the 11 years subsequent
it will take many years for the
estimated 1.4 million
of council taxpayers money to be
recouped
how was this spend justified given brett
did not ask for
this replacement and the last engineers
report of 2015-16
did not recommend a replacement
you'd like me to reply to uh yes i think
i'm not sure that all of us
got that i was interrupted did all
councillors um
manage to hear the supplementary
question
yes yes yes right
okay yes counselor would you like to
respond please
i will and i think that there's another
misunderstanding here
um and and this has been um something
which has been aired over the last 18
months
in that the council should somehow draw
up a business plan and decide whether
it's
financially sensible and a good business
proposition to replace the birth
the council has a contractual commitment
to provide a birth for unloading the
aggregate
so the calculation of what profit the
council might make out about against the
cost
is not relevant the council has a
contractual commitment
and in order to depart from that
contractual commitment it would have to
pay
um significant sums to extract itself
so we have to replace the birth the
birth has to be replaced because he's
not
fit for purpose um we weren't able to
use it for parts of last winter because
we took the view that in bad weather it
could be a risk to people using it
um it has to be replaced and it can't be
replaced like for like
so that process has been tendered um bam
that'll have won the contract
and we're in the process of doing that
replacement
before the winter weather sets in and
anything which poses a risk to our
ability to do that before the winter
weather
poses a financial risk to this council
because we have a contract
and if we are responsible for brett's
not being able to bring in the aggregate
over the winter months by by ship
then they will have to bring it in by
lorry and we will have to meet the
additional cost so there's a risk we'd
have to beat the additional costs
so that's why the project is going ahead
that's why it's a priority
um and i can't comment on the actual
detail of what
councillor wing says about the contract
um i'm not aware that those figures are
accurate
um but certainly the cap it's not a
matter of a calculation it's a matter of
a
contractual commitment made by the
council many years ago
and neither she nor i were party to that
commitment at the time
thank you very much indeed councillor
everett agenda item 7b
question number two from a member
regarding anti-social behavior
against beach huts i call upon
councillor bailey councillor bailey are
you there
i am good evening my question is to
council douglas
um ongoing antisocial behavior on the
beaches late at night includes
vandalizing
beach huts using their wood and private
property to build fires on the beach
how can tgc work with your leisure and
the police
to increase security and enforcement
perhaps ring fencing
some of the income to pay for cctv
thank you very much indeed councillor um
councillor bailey i call upon councillor
duckworth to respond
thank you thank you for your question
council bailey
your leisure manage the beach huts and
provide security on fridays saturdays
and sundays
they commence patrols at 8 30 pm and
finish patrols at 2 am
we are not aware of any incidents of
vandalism to the beach huts
that have been reported to the council
this season you'll at
your leisure are aware of one incident
in order to determine the most
appropriate and effective action to take
we do need incidents to be reported in
detail
with information on the location where
the anti-social behaviour is happening
this will enable us to work together
with your leisure and other agencies to
resolve
persistent problems councillor bailey do
you have a supplementary
uh yes i do thank you thank you for your
reply and and i agree with
the reporting obviously um
i'm under the impression that there are
some mobile cctv cameras around that tgc
use
and i just wondered if these could be
used to utilize during the summer months
on the proms and beaches i believe there
there are
um i know there's cctv probably mobile
ones that i also
know that everybody wants cctv but um
it's certainly something that um we can
look into
um but you know there are resource
issues there
so um but yeah thank you for drawing my
attention to it
thank you very much indeed councillor
darkworth agenda item 7c
question number three from a member
regarding re-examination
of temporary traveler sites i call upon
councillor ropa
councilloropa can you unmute
yes hello thank you tdc has a legal
obligation to provide
sites for travellers sites at potton
street and shot and dane
road are being put forward to cabinet
but potton street in particular has
strong local objections
in addition only having two sites could
cause problems
could the whole process now be
re-examined
thank you councillor ropa i do think
council whitehead was going to respond
but councillor everett is going to
respond for her
councillor everett yes indeed uh thank
you chair uh thank you
uh for the question councillor roper and
um having to take i got to take the
advice that councillor wing gave me in
response to the previous question
the answer is yes
thank you very much councillor council
rupert do you have a supplementary
um yes um i was at a parish council
meeting at saint nicholas
uh virtually on tuesday and i found out
that the whole process
is being started again and that those
two sites now have
been sort of taken off the calendar as
it were
um so i'd just like to ask um if
landowners in the area
um could be asked if they have more
suitable sites
that they could make available um if you
want an example there's a large amount
of unused land at a certain disused
airport near here
thank you yes yes very amusing
uh back to your council everett yes and
in fact um counselor roper
that's exactly what the report gains
cabinet on the 17th uh talks about
what we've decided is that we should put
it through the local plan review process
which is a formal process
and that will invol involve a call for
sites
um and it will also involve a much more
structured and comprehensive
consultation process
and uh one of the concerns that i did
have is that the call for temporary
sites wasn't being subjected to
a comprehensive consultation process for
very good reasons but
partly around coving and partly around
the nature of the temperate sites
but i think that the reassurance that
members of the public will get
from a proper process put through the
local brand review
is certainly very worthwhile and we will
certainly be looking at what other
land is available uh for this purpose
thank you very much councillor everett
moving on to agenda item 70
question number four from a member
regarding temporary traveller sites
i call upon council pew can you
unmute council thank you chair
um and yeah i'll try not to um i'll try
not to rerun through what
council rope has asked um but i will
repeat my question i submitted i know
things have moved on
um since i submitted it but i will i
will still read it out
as travel incursions continue to rise
across senate not least in my own wards
what measures is this council taking to
secure temporary sites to tackle this
issue
return thank you very much councilman
pugh returning to councillor everett
um well i think i've um i think i've
i've responded that
there's a report going to cabinet on the
17th um and there'll be an opportunity
for discussions out there
thank you very much everett uh in the
circumstance councillor pugh have you
got a supplementary
uh yes i do thank you chair and yes
leader i
my supplementary particularly
considering as you as you've
uh just mentioned the uh the change in
the decision that is being put
proposal that has been put to cabinet
next week
and particularly that the call for sites
will be incorporated into
potentially a review of the local plan
and can you assure me
that any review or call for science that
is implemented with this review for the
local plan
as you said earlier in response to
council europa will be far more
wide-reaching
far more um consulted with residents
across
than it um and actually that when the
decision is made to narrow it down to a
few options that it isn't narrowed down
to only two
when two sites are preferred to be
progressed and before it's gone to
consultation
um so that we can ensure that actually
as many residents across the aisle
consulted on
what is a very important issue thank you
councillor
back to you councillor everett uh uh yes
well i mean
the nature of the local planning review
is that he involves a much wider
consultation so that will certainly be
happening
um i i would like to thank councillor
pugh for his um
for his left for his email which he sent
um four minutes before the cabinet
meeting in which we were discussing the
sites
in which he made a case um against
potton street
um obviously four minutes wasn't really
enough time for cabinet to receive and
consider the email
but we did read it after the meeting
after we decided not to consider the
item
and then i was sent an email um which
was sent
by councillor pugh um at 6 11 on the
same evening
probably about 10 minutes after it
finished in which he wrote to the chair
of the parish council and nicholas
weights and
and said that due to procedural failings
brought to light by himself and other
councillors
this decision has been delayed until the
cabinet meeting on the 19th of august
which was quite a surprise to um to mr
bryant who he wrote to because
he in fact was the person who raised the
issue with me
that caused the item to be dropped and
i'd never heard anything on the subject
from council of pew
thank you well leader i do
raised this with apologi um on the day
ahead of the cabinet meeting
with careers
you've had your supplementary counselor
here councillor evra thank you very much
indeed
moving on to agenda item 7e question
number five from a member regarding
beach lifts in ramsgate and broadstairs
i call upon councillor rolfe
thank you chair uh it is council's duty
to look
after everyone in the community all the
people
and disabled people were excluded from
enjoying
the beach on their doorsteps
in brussels and ramsgate can the council
explained to me why they have not acted
quickly
to fix the lift to be ready
for those people to use it the council
know
that well many residents in sanet are
older
and disabled and have promised to
prioritize their needs
thank you thank you council ross
i call upon councillor duckworth to
respond councillor
thank duckworth for your question
councillorf um there is disability
access to ramsgate main sands
via harbour parade and to the other end
of the beach
car parking includes designating
disabled bays along marina esplanade
there is disability access via the
pavilion gardens onto the boardwalk at
viking bay
we've now extended the matting so that
it joins the boardwalk
providing additional access straight off
harbour street
there are designated disabled bays in
the harbour car park
due to the restrictions imposed by the
government's response to the covert 19
emergency
both lifts had to be closed although the
appropriate annual maintenance has still
been undertaken
when the lockdown restrictions were
eased there was still the issue of
achieving legal requirements for
social distancing in a confined space
such as a lift
the decision was made to keep both lifts
closed but we were approached by a
residence group in broad stairs to look
at the option of
opening the lift the first issues has
been the availability of specialist
contractors
to repair the lift so that it would be
fully operational
many manufacturing companies are still
on furlough
the second issue relates to compliance
with social distancing requirements
tdc does not have the resources to have
the lift staffed at all times increase
cleaning ensure only those who need it
get access
and that they are from the same family
and wear face coverings
discussions are still ongoing with the
residents group
due to both of these issues not being
resolved the list the lift unfortunately
remains closed
thank you thank you very much councillor
duckworth uh council roth i would just
mention that
you didn't actually stick to the full
wording of your question
and i just for all members listening in
at the moment
it is important that the question is
adhered to properly
enabling the respondent to reply
accurately
so bearing that in mind could you please
move on to your supplementary which i
presume you may have
yeah i apologize for that um uh can the
council reassure me
and this resident of thanet that council
will use
winter period to service and make sure
lifts are ready for summer to be used
not pass it to member of the public to
take responsibility away
thank you um as far as i understand the
um maintenance and servicing um went
ahead and
um i can't see the reason why it won't
go ahead next year
um but obviously i'll keep an eye on
that and get back to you
if there's any issues thank you thank
you very much indeed councillor
duckworth
moving on to agenda item 7f question
number six from a member regarding
anti-social behavior
at dane park i call upon counselor
taylor
taylor good evening it's a question to
council whitehead
do please proceed council whitehead you
and i have spoke frequently regarding
measures
that we can take to ensure that dane
park
dane valley and dane park areas are as
safe
as welcoming as possible i know we would
like
to fully discuss our approaches to this
so can we outline current measures
and your plans please
thank you very much counseling and of
course councillor whitehead is not
able to receive your question this
evening so i'll turn to councillor
everett
councillor alvin is going to answer this
one just to be different
all right come to alban uh you're in the
chair for the moment then
council alvin are you there can you on
my a mutual microphone sorry
sorry just for a change chair just to
give councillor every arrest
um the answer is the
community safety team are working with
the park
and open spaces team to try and resolve
some of the issues raised by councillors
and residents
such as unauthorized traveler camps and
anti-social
behaviour it is important that any such
matters
as assaults are reported repo i'll
reported
to kent police
the community safety team work
alongside
the community uh sorry the kent police
and the task force to act in a
multi-agency
approach to the specific issues raised
the community safety team are aware that
the
community needs and aspirations
are part of the scoping exercise
for the authentic community safety
partnership
also i have uh already agreed
uh to meet with ward councillors and
residents
at dane park next week
to listen to their concerns
and to see what can be done thank you
chairman
thank you councillor album cancer taylor
do you have a supplementary question
no i'll just um look forward to next
next weekend thank you very much council
auburn
thank you thank you very much well that
concludes
gender item 7 and our questions from
members this evening
moving therefore onto agenda item 8
motions
on notice one motion on notice has been
received in accordance with council
procedure rule
3 agenda item eight a notice on motion
park avenue broad says i call upon
councillor garner
councilman are you there to read your
motion
i am thank you and i remind you at this
point
stick to the exact wording of your
motion otherwise
um i'll have to get council to agree any
change
okay then i'm um i'm
just about to do that thank you pardon
to consider a notice of motion to
require the owner of the area of
woodland of park avenue
east of parkwood close broadstairs
land registry reference k-61934
to replant any trees covered by tree
protection orders
within that area following the recent
heavy filling
and to reaffirm its current view that
the area should remain
as open space and woodland
thank you very much unique councillor
ghana do you have a second or for
this motion i believe councillor bailey
i'd like to second the motion
thank you thank you very much indeed
councillor bailey now in accordance with
council procedure rule 3.7 a member of
the controlling political group is
entitled to reply
and i believe this is councillor
duckworth councillor duckworth
are you there
councillor duckworth
am i to take it yeah are you there
counselor duckworth
uh yeah um i don't have a reply for this
i haven't um
you're not going well that's fine no
it's just that you have the right to do
so
i'll be hopping group if you wish to do
so okay then right i'll move on
do we wish to debate this motion in
which case i need a proposer and a
second
do i have a proposal
am i allowed to propose it well you've
already preferred the motion so
i need a proposed to debate from
somebody else
i'll propose it yeah counselor do i have
a second uh
second it councillor wing we'll second
it
thank you very much indeed members
should note that this motion relates to
a cabinet function
council can only resolve to pass this to
cabinet for consideration
would somebody like to please start the
debate
maybe maybe i could then as the um
yes if you'd like too much thank you
well i welcome the opportunity to
propose this motion to cancel today
i am a little disappointed that i have
to as we heard earlier from amanda
the representative of park avenue
woodland group
more than 40 mature trees were fulfilled
earlier this year
in clear breach of tree protection
orders dated from 1956 to 1985
there is little question that the
landowners have a case to answer
and this motion calls on the council
or the cabinet to take the action which
should have been taken months ago
i.e to serve a tree replacement order
on the landowner to make them plant
replacement trees on the
site and additionally to reaffirm that
this woodland should remain
as open space woodland in the future
we have all been contacted by local
residents about the impact this has had
on their local environment and on the
residents themselves
and it's important that we recognize the
strength of feeling
across planet for the protection and
enhancement of our pressure stop
biodiversity
not enough has been done since we
declared a climate emergency 15 months
ago
to protect our already dwindling tree
cover across
thanet their protection isn't high
enough priority
we continue to make it much too
difficult for tree protection orders to
be both applied for and then implemented
while also making it too easy for
developers to ignore the limited number
of new
trees and hedges they plant on new
estates
leaving them to die this is an
opportunity for us to send a clear
message
to others who are considering similar
action that fanuc district council
takes the protection of our trees and
hedges seriously
and i urge you all to support this
motion thank you
thank you ghana i think you might find
that there's more um
interest in this matter than you realize
i do have a number of speakers
who would like to put their names
forward starting with councillor bailey
councillor bailey would you like to take
over here
thank you um yeah the i mean the
fellaini i can't go over the arrogance
actually criminal arrogance of these
people that you know
say they want to cut down one tree they
get permission to cut down one tree and
they go and cut down
forty odd uh you can reasonably assume
from
their actions they might have plans you
know to put in a
uh development application at some time
in the future
i haven't been able to find one at the
moment um
and i can't find any permissions within
the local plan for um
any future development on this land um
so and obviously with the local plan
adoption
we i think the council are in a much
stronger place now to
refuse such speculative uh applications
um i'm part of the local review group
and
i did forward a suggestion a while back
that um
any designated woodland like this should
be incorporated
and registered within the local plan
like the green wedges are to afford them
more protection
um so i think three things i think
i know we've had the covid situation
this year and i understand that
uh the council have been under pressure
but it's been a long time i think it's
february this this was uh
action was taken and and there's still
not been any
um expedition of the order to replace
the lost trees
there's been nothing no legal
enforcement
um as far as i'm aware so i think they
it really needs to be done now so
i think there's three things that need
to be done straight away all the
remaining trees on the site need to be
protected
um the council must expedite the order
to replace the lost trees like for like
and an example needs to be made um via
legal enforcement to stop it happening
elsewhere as well thank you
thank you chair um can you hear me yes
okay yeah as um
four out of the six questions from the
public this afternoon
on the subject of trees obviously it is
um
of high importance to us i mean for me
personally it has great i have great
interest in this as
i'm striving to run a project to replace
trees that i have willfully or
unwillfully been
removed from from the island and i
personally
and i'm sure other members that have an
interest in this would like to actually
see
a report that our tree officer could
prepare
for us to explain the full sequence of
events that led up to this
and also the legal entities that
have either been broken or not broken um
and i'd like that to be shared with full
council and before it actually goes to
cabinet um
i think we all have a big interest in it
and i would really like to see
that sort of information and we utilize
our tree officer who is obviously an
expert in this field
um regarding also the the subject of
tpos
because um obviously once it goes into
cabinet then
we don't necessarily get the full
benefit of the information that would
come out
prior to that so i think this is a full
interest at all council so
um i sort of i suppose it's a sub
proposal
that you know we could have access to a
report prepared by our own tree officers
so that we can be all
full fully okay with whether laws have
been broken or not broken
and how we can actually eliminate this
type of practice in the future thank you
chair
thank you very much councillor ashby and
that's your fact that is an important
point that you make because that is
indeed very reason why as a council we
can't make a decision this evening
because it would be uninformed
so thank you very much indeed for that
moving on councillor album
hey there councillor alvin yes thank you
chair um
i i fully support this motion chair
and as a previous officer of this
council who
uh who would deal with such matters
um the issue of having a blanket
preservation orders on areas such as
this one in park avenue in
in broadcast is very difficult it's very
difficult to enforce and the reason for
that is
is that when these blanket tpos when
these blanket preservation orders were
put in especially the 1950s
56 one and certainly in court cases that
i've been involved in
dealing with such such matches is that
the self-seeded trees are not covered
by the blanket preservation order so
depending you you've then got to
identify the trees that were originally
there
at the time of the uh of the
preservation order which goes back to
1956 and subsequently
one i think as councillor ghana says in
1985.
now i'm quite sure uh that the
planning enforcement team who will deal
with this matter and just to just to
slightly go
uh off-key to what council ashby has
said i think this is a matter for
the the the tree officer will only go
and look on site as to see
what the quality of the trees are he
doesn't give he has no
he has no um official
dealings with uh any of the enforcement
side side of the matter
um i'm sure knowing the planning
enforcement team
as i as i do chair have got fully
involved in this and and are
investigating to the best of their
ability
and also uh these trees have to be
identified so that any prosecution that
can take place
uh can do so in the knowledge that the
council has done everything that it can
to ensure that a prosecution should it
go ahead can be successful
um so i i think as as members whilst i
fully support this
fully to the hill because we should make
these people pay
and i've and i'm fully for that um but
i'm
i and i also agree with councillor ashby
that we should have the full advice
coming back to members and probably at
fault at
full council um i i just wanted to make
those points chairman thank you
thank you very much indeed councillor
album that's good uh moving on to
councillor
piper council piper you're next
thank you chairman i i think possibly
for the benefit of the public who are
watching in on this meeting as well
because i'm sure all of us elected
members are fully supportive of this
motion and would want it to go to
cabinet for their consideration
and their reports then uh back to us i'm
wondering if
um absolute silence if you were to ask
mr chairman for
uh only those who are opposing
this to speak up and that you would take
a resounding silence
as a confirmation that we wish it to go
to cabinet
i wonder if that might uh be something
you would consider doing
thank you thank you very much indeed uh
councillor piper i shall stick to
procedure
just for the moment well that's a very
good idea may we'll take it
up uh but we have one more speaker i've
got counselor everett who'd like to come
in at this point
yes thank you chair i mean i didn't
intend to speak on this but um
i'd just like to assure members that um
this matter
was brought to my attention by the by
the green group of councillors and they
asked me to look into it
um and i have had a very extensive uh
briefing from
mr livingston in planning on what's been
going on with this site
um and i can assure you that it is
exceptionally complicated
and has required a lot of detective work
by our planning officers
to understand um the tree preservation
orders
that are in place which come from
different decades
have different terms and as councillor
alvin has described
don't necessarily cover self-seeding
trees or particular types of tree
so they've had quite a job to work out
which trees were there in the first
place were actually protected
um but i'm satisfied and i'm not going
to go into the detail of it
in full council now but i'm satisfied
that our officers are taking a very
active approach to this
issue on this site and i absolutely
recognize the public concern of it
the public concern about it and you
shouldn't assume that because you
haven't seen anything
and you haven't heard anything that the
council is not doing anything
because that isn't the case now as to
how um
the information can be shared with
members i think we'd have to take a
um a discussion about that because
obviously it's um
i don't quite know understand the
legalities of it if i'm totally honest
i would like to see a member's briefing
around it so that members could
understand
some of what the issues are and we'll
take some uh we'll have some discussion
and no doubt when it comes to cabinet
we'll be able to bring some advice
a report there will be in the public
domain obviously but i understand
members want
more opportunity to talk about it and as
leader you have my commitment that we
will find a way for that to happen
um as far as is consistent with good
practice than the law
thank you council everest and i think
that's well received and we should look
forward to that
uh there are no other speakers therefore
i call upon councillor ghana to read out
the wording of his motion once again
councillor ghana okay okay yeah i shall
go back to that
so the the wording of the motion is to
consider
a notice of motion to require the owner
of the area of woodland off park avenue
east of parkwood close board stairs land
registry reference
k-61934 to replant any trees
covered by tree protection orders within
the area
following the recent heavy felling and
to reaffirm its current view
that the area should remain as open
space woodland
thank you very much indeed councillor
ghana now my feeling here
is that the uh the councillors are very
much in favor of this motion
being put to cabinet therefore i shall
look to do that
assuming that if anyone is against this
motion they speak out now
and i'm not getting anything against
which means i've got
the whole council in favor and therefore
this motion will be put forward to
cabinet
thank you very much indeed councillors
moving therefore onto agenda item nine
the leaders report as this meeting is
entirely virtual the leaders report has
been circulated all members and
published on the council website
i'd call upon therefore councillor
gained comment on or
asked questions in relation to the
leaders report council again being the
leader of the opposition
in council council again uh thank you
chairman
um i'm just going to focus on three of
the subjects raised in your report
but thank you uh for the report um
leader and i think the way you now put
it online
is is very very helpful and it's a very
good good way to progress
the new station sanit parkway this is
definitely good news
and what inspirational thinking on the
part of the previous administration to
go for this
as you say the 2 million is only to be
used for supporting
economic growth in saanich and the new
station will definitely do that
the scheme will cost 34 million most of
it is grants
but there's 5.8 million from kcc
and the 2 million from us our
contribution is actually relatively
minor compared to some
but no one foresaw covid and the
financial pressures it
has and will bring so you say there is a
further bid
to the new stations fund this will give
a reduction to kcc
but how much will it give to our council
will you actually be able to get our
contribution reduced
i understand the grant funding will be
spent first
and any unused will be returned to kcc
so pressure needs to be put on kcc and i
would really like to know how much of
our 2 million
you hope to get back on manson
i'm not surprised you are not in support
of this i would think you would be
thrown out of the south senate labour
party if you said otherwise
as everyone knows i am my group are firm
supporters
we have been and always will be you
absolutely have a duty
to work constructively with the owners
as to manson being used as a lorry park
i have received assurances from kcc
officers that thus this will be an
absolute last resort
it is not on the government agenda they
have invested in a 27
acre site in sevington for 2 000 lorries
this will also become a border control
site
there will also be a contraflow system
in place on the m20
with a movable barrier when operation
brock
as it is now called they keep changing
the name is in place
uh finally on performance issues i am
concerned that the peer review
will look at culture it's the governance
that's the issue
but as we are now having a briefing the
scope of the review
can be discussed and hopefully from this
a decision can be made
for this to be a wide-reaching a
wide-reaching review with a focus on
governance
this whole issue cannot be political it
should be cross-party
with contributions from all groups it's
a good move that you are now bringing in
an external auditor from grant thornton
this is what my group have been asking
for and hopefully
this will cover the governance issues
it is vital that no review should
interfere
with the workings and remit of the idsc
but the question is is a peer review the
right way to go
i appreciate that asking for an
investigation
could be ineffective bearing in mind it
could not look
at statutory officer behavior as this
would indeed
impact on the idsc however it is
absolutely essential
that whatever is set up is wide and deep
ranging
and effective enough to bring the
governance within this organization
back to the standard to be expected of a
success
success successful council although i
said this should not be political
basically leader it's on your head to
make sure whatever is put in place
works thank you thank you council again
uh councillor everett would you like to
respond
um uh yes chair thank you and um yes
thank partway is good news now um i do
have a particular interest in infantic
parkway because i'm a resident of cliffs
and as people like to remind me
um and certainly i look forward to the
delivery of the station
um and i'd like to pay tribute to the
cross-party working that's gone on
um with conservatives elsewhere in the
council uh
and sorry elsewhere in king um
because we have worked together on this
one we do see it as a very big boost for
the fanatic economy
um how much money will we get back
um i suppose i suppose what i would say
to councillor game is um she has to
decide how much faith she has in the
conservative leader of
county council he and i have had very
constructive and amicable discussions
about this
um i think that until we know what the
outcome of the new station's fund bid is
um neither of us wanted to put a figure
on it but i have say i put in my
confidence in
in roger golf on this issue because i've
found him to be
um you know we've worked together on
this issue um and i i assume that she
has confidence in him but she would have
opportunities no doubt to reply to that
my position on madison airport has is
unchanged from my previous
tenure of the council i have concerns
about its impact on ramsgate and in
particular night flights
but i do recognize that this council has
to engage with the situation as it is
um and not um try and overturn things
which are already in place
um i think she's wrong about um the use
of manchester united as a
airport park as a lorry park um i was
gonna meet him with uh
michael gove earlier in the week and
kent mps it's very clear
from that meeting that they see uh
manson as a
useful contingency um if there are
traffic problems they haven't reached a
uh
they haven't agreed they don't have an
agreement with rsp but they but some
people in that meeting were very bullish
about getting it
so i'm afraid it may be coming down the
track um
the peer review well we're going to have
the um discussion on
on tuesday um with members and members
would
say what they want to say there
absolutely we've got to get the
governance right but it's
a question of running the process in the
right order um i'm not bringing in the
external auditor
and i can assure council again and other
members of the council they're not
bringing in the external auditor
because the external officer will decide
what she's going to do
that's not how it works at all but i'm
absolutely committed
to having the governance of this
organization examined
and to prove that everything is in order
thank you
thank you very much indeed leader i call
upon councillor reverend piper to
comment on and
ask questions in relation to the leaders
report council piper are you there
thank you gentlemen uh thank you leader
for this report um i would like to add
my vote of approval to the manner of
releasing the report in the way that
you're doing
but could i ask that it's made much
easier to send it on to my personal
computer because my home screen is much
bigger and i can actually see it
um i would not of course publish it more
widely
than its intended audience but it lasts
for security reasons
for me to receive it i have to agree
with your sentiments about the council
departments functioning really well
in difficult circumstances build it and
they will come
someone once said and our beaches are
being targeted by visitors which is
great
but personally i believe the teams work
exceptionally hard
and many of those visitors and some
local residents sadly seem to treat
their efforts with disdain
enforcement can often be self-funding so
i wonder isn't it time that officers
patrol beaches and spot fine people
walking away
and abandoning their rubbish they do it
in morocco
why not here i would like to add that i
think
councillor whitehead has been doing an
outstanding job
working with housing in what clearly has
been a very difficult time
i'm delighted to hear too that
democratic services are being considered
for an achievement award
from their peers fewer things are
perhaps more rewarding
than such praise from people who know
and understand your work
leader therefore i think you can tell i
think most members would agree with your
sentiments of
praise for council departments and in
some cases
uh individuals
the council is working really really
well
in really difficult circumstances what
puzzles me and many of my colleagues
though
and i'll try not to be too repetitive
here is why then the need for a peer
review
the last time this council had one
almost everyone was in agreement that it
was needed the culture was exceptionally
toxic
mass walkouts by members shouting during
the chamber during meetings
as well as very difficult working
relationships between members and
officers
and amongst employees not much of that
kind of behavior
is evident this time so why the rush
for such a wide-ranging review
i'm thinking that perhaps it is
unfortunate that the briefing that's
coming
wasn't held last tuesday because the
briefing meetings are held fortnightly
and perhaps it could have formed uh
given us a more informed position for
this meeting this evening
i am on record as saying i think it
would be taking a blunderbuss to the
whole
organization and it could undo all the
recent progress that's been made
and create distrust this time leader i
really don't think that a peer review
would attract
anything like the level of support
needed to make it work
whatever may or may not be needed i
think a laser beam approach
is far more appropriate thank you mr
chairman
thank you very much indeed counselor
pipeline i call upon the leader to
respond council everett
uh yes uh thank you councillor pogba i
think we'll we'll we'll take the issue
of
how you access the report perhaps
outside the council meeting but i hear
what you're saying
um and i welcome you your comments about
the beaches and certainly
it occurred to me that the staff the
staff that we've got working so hard on
the beaches in all that heat we're doing
a tremendous job and they certainly do
need
our thanks and our respect and it's i'm
just sad that so often the story is
about litter
um because the council staff don't leave
the litter i'm afraid our visitors to
and sometimes our residents do but that
is a big
issue for us on the beaches in terms of
enforcement um we are looking to
put our bylaws into a public space
protection order
which will allow enforcement at the
moment our bylaws can only be enforced
by prosecution
which isn't really practical um and i
think once we've got a psp
in place around it which is a process
needs consultation we'll be in a much
better place to do
enforcement i absolutely agree with your
comments about councillor whitehead and
um
you know i made my comments about
councillor head to um to the authentic
news yesterday
i think she's an outstanding counsellor
i'm sorry she's not here tonight
um i look forward to seeing her back um
at the next council meeting and
obviously i work very closely with her
on the subject of the peer review well
we couldn't bring uh that to the
previous briefing because
um the lga wouldn't have been ready to
have um to told you what they planned to
do
um a fortnight ago um and the reason why
we brought it forward now
is that very serious allegations have
been made and those allegations have
been reproduced in the press
particularly around issues of bullying
and harassment and members need to have
confidence
um that that isn't a current and
accurate characterization
of the council as a whole i'm confident
that's the case but i think council
officers and
council members need an opportunity to
tell an independent authority that
we need a rounded overview and on the
subject of a laser focus
absolutely we're going to look at the
issues that we want to look at
we're not going to look at everything
that the council does um but we'll talk
about that at the briefing next week and
you'll have every opportunity to make
your input there but thank you for your
response to council piper
thank you very much indeed leader i call
upon councillor ghana to comment on or
ask questions in relation to the leaders
report councillor ghana are you there
i am i am still here yes thank you very
much
um yeah i'd also like to join
councillors game and piper in thanking
the leader for his report and how it was
delivered
and i would like to join him in
recognizing the hard work
put in by council staff across the
district who've had to contend
in unique circumstances to deliver
services to residents as he says
following his visits to dane park and
manson green depot
a number of these staff have to work in
outdated facilities
and i agree with him that improvements
to these areas need to be
high priority post covered
we've had a busy council meeting at
which it's been good to spend time
listening to residents concerns on our
tree coverage
and to debate our response so i won't
take up my full five minutes
and will focus on the high priority
areas
our views on fanuc parkway station
and the granting of manson dco are well
known
and haven't changed we are disappointed
with the news that approval has been
given for the new fanuc parkway station
in cliffs and
the enormous cost company 34 million
pound is going to result
in the loss of greenfield sites
including countless mature trees
and long-term disruption for cliffs and
resin
all for the sake of shaving a couple of
minutes off journey times to london
as for manston as we see a huge
reduction in air travel in airports
with spare capacity for cargo flights we
remain opposed to the granting of the
dco by the minister
overruling the planning inspectors
concerns
and support the judicial review of this
decision
i'd like to thank the leader for keeping
us informed on developments
relating to the serious issues that are
raised in the recent article
in the municipal journal as a result of
the leaked letter
as he intimates these allegations are
not new
and we agree with councillor game and
piper
that they need to be properly addressed
through an external audit
of covenants and culture we believe
there is an
urgent need for greater transparency at
tdc
and hope that investigation into the
culture
will include um will include a situation
where members request for information
about the camp
council's plans are made increasingly
difficult and hope that being
high on the agenda no council that is
operating properly
should have anything to fear from
sharing information and allowing
external bodies to scrutinize its work
thank you thank you councillor ghana
back to you leader uh yes thank you
chair and thanks
thank you to councillor ghana for his
comments um
yeah i mean i i it was the first time
that i've been to uh the manson road in
dane park deposit i must admit that i
never got there
when i was a councillor here previously
and i would encourage
members of the council to take such
opportunities as they get to visit those
sites because
some of our most important staff and our
most visible staff work out of those
bases
um and i don't think that the conditions
are satisfactory
and i think we need to look in our
reorganization's postcode
to make improvements for those staff
because i think um
you know we're probably not doing them
we're doing them a disservice and the
current conditions for for
historic and and understandable
financing reasons but i think we need to
do better
um you know i'm never going to agree
with the fedec green position on
on parkway station you know it seems
extraordinary to me that the green party
are opposed to a railway station but
there we go
um this is this is this is going to
leave a 26 million pounds of public
money into the district
which would not come in for any other
project
i have every confidence that in five or
ten years time
people will think that those who oppose
this station were made
i think it will be successful and it's
not about journey times to london
it's about accessibility because
presently to give you an example and i
am an example i
if i go on the train i drive to ramsgate
station i drive to minster station or i
drive to sandwich station and get on the
train
so i'm already driving to get on the
train and that is an addition to my
journey time so it's not how long the
train takes to get from ramsgate to
cliffs end
is how long it takes for me to get to
cliffs into ramsgate now i'm not
i'm not stupid enough to think that the
council should contribute and the
government should contribute to build a
station for me
but there is a great deal of development
to be done in fanet
we need growth we need more prosperity
and we need
change and i'm afraid that this strange
argument which goes around about we've
got seven stations already why do we
need an eighth
you know perhaps we should invest in
dumpster park i don't know um it just
misses the point completely we need a
station which is where that station is
or at that point on the line
in order to open up other areas um
and finally on the point of transparency
i think that's a good one and i think
it's a great issue for
for the green party councillors um to
raise with the
lga team in the peer review and let's
have a discussion about it
let's see what let's see what they think
about it thank you
thank you very much indeed leader uh
moving therefore
on to agenda item 10 the report of the
chairman of the over
security panel i call upon our very
experienced chairman of
scrutiny councillor bayford to present
his report thank you
yes thank you chairman um i hope that
the report is self-explanatory but i
will
obviously be happy to answer any
questions that members have
what i would like to note in passing
though is that members have actively
engaged in identifying items
for future scrutiny these were ranked
using the matrix developed by democratic
services
and at our last meeting it was agreed
that over time the panel will work
through this list
i would also like to report that the
memorial working party has now been set
up
will hold its first meeting later in the
month this obviously relates to issues
surrounding the uncle matt plaque
in broad stairs and other issues thank
you
thank you very much indeed castle
bayford do members have any comments
would you like to let me know now if
anyone would like to speak
it doesn't look like it so thank you
very much indeed councillor bayford
moving on to agenda item 11 the budget
monitoring report number one for 2020
21. i will now ask the cabinet member
for finance administration and community
wealth building councillor yates to
present
the report counseling
yes i am thank you chair in the general
fund 2019 to 20 budget
than it does the council overspends by
around 500 000 pounds
in order to set the budget for 2020 to
21 which is this year's budget we had to
find savings of 730
000 pounds many of the planned savings
we put into the budget in february are
now unlikely to be delivered because of
covert
on top of this the pandemic is added to
our costs and negatively affected our
income generation
our current estimates suggest the total
shortfall from lost income and
additional
expenditure of 5.6 million pounds
we have estimated government grants of
2.6 million pounds
this leaves a budget gap of 3 million
any longer-term financial impact of
coronavirus will be picked up in the 21
to 22 budget
next year's budget will also have to
address the underlying budget problem
of undelivered savings even if our
income bounces back
today cabinet is recommended to council
action to address the current year gap
cabinet does not recommend cutting
services or making redundancies so the
proposals provide
funding for the three million pounds
from reserves
the council already has low reserves
before coronavirus
so there were difficult choices to be
made as to which reserves to use
cabinet proposals are set out in annex
1. by making a decision now
council is showing that it wishes to
address the budget problems head-on
this gives reassurance to the section
151 officer that the council will take
the decisions to address the coveted
losses
cabinet proposes doing this by
allocating some of those losses to
specific reserves
some 2.2 million pounds of them the
remaining eight hundred thousand pounds
will be held in the covid shortfall
reserve
and only be allocated service budgets on
income loss
um for example um sorry i've lost my
place
this helps manage the uncertainty on our
estimates some estimates on income loss
for example may turn out to be not as
bad as we think
so not all of the shortfall reserve may
be called upon if this happens
depending on the size of any balance at
the end of the year we may need to make
a decision as to whether or not we
retain the reserve
the decision to use the are limited
reserves should not be taken lightly
once we've used them they're gone and we
have relatively low reserves before the
pandemic
the section 151 officer assures us that
kova does not yet
dealt a fatal blow to our finances but
there is very little headroom if
unforeseen costs materialize in the
future we do not know what the long-term
impact of covid will be on the council
finances
and we may well have to make further
tough decisions in the weeks and months
to follow
none of these choices are easy but i
hope the council can agree on this list
of reserves in order to protect jobs
and frontline services i move the
recommendations
thank you very much indeed councillor
yates have you got a secondary as a
secondary here
we'd like to set forward i'll second
that chair councillor alban
councillor alvin i have your second
thing thank you very much indeed just to
remind councillors
the motion is that uh council approves
firstly the general fund review budget
2021 forecast position
secondly the general fund capital
program 2020 21 forecast position
thirdly the proposals to fund the budget
gap created by kovic 19.
uh we have a recorded vote at this point
can i hand you over to the monitoring
officer
either monitoring officer
um before we start sorry um
do you want to debate the motion ah yes
yes indeed thank you very much indeed mr
hughes
uh yes members i've jumped too soon
is there anybody who would like to to
mate to talk on the motion at all
i don't have anybody who's come up
so far i'm taking that as a no
so over to you monitoring officer uh
thank you chairman um i'm gonna ask
members
to vote either in favor to abstain or
vote against
councillor alban four
councillor ara four
that's the ashby
council ashby
i'll come back
a jill bayford four that's a robert
bayford
four that's the boyd four
that's a campbell four
that's a coleman cook four
councillor christendom four
that's a curry four
that's a day
for castle dexter
for he has a duckworth
for everett
that's a farance four
that's a fellows four
that's a game four count for the ghana
four out of green
gather green
gregory thor has a heart
or counselor hopkinson
that's a huxley four counselor keen
four councillor pat moore
four that's what other than
catholic
four thank you so i had a technical
problem
counselor linda piper
council linda piper
four thank you councillor stuart piper
for the other pots
she said apologies okay thank you sorry
uh counselor pew
that's a rolf full
that's the rogers four
that was a roper four
councillor roseki oh
that's not david saunders
four that's my maeve saunders
four that's a savage four
that's a scooby four
he has a scott
councilman scott four
thank you that's a shrub
four
four cats are right four
council of the eights fourth
council of green present and four
thank you i think that's everybody now
let's check i'll catch a pew
castle pew
okay that's partisan nem con
chairman thank you very much indeed
monitoring officer
that did sound to me um unanimous
moves were absent thank you very much
indeed moving on to agenda item
12 the revised hra budget and monitoring
20 20 21 and hra provisional out turn
2019-2020 i'll now ask the cabinet
member
finance administration community wealth
building council yates to present the
report council yates back to you
thank you chair the housing revenue
account is having to cope with the same
uncertainty as the general fund
the main potential impact of covid is on
housing rent income collection
this may yet be insulated from some of
the worst effects of covid
as about two-thirds of our rent income
is from benefits however there will be
an impact
perhaps a bigger challenge to the hra
now and over the long term is in
accommodating the transfer of east kent
housing to the council
i believe there is agreement across the
council that this is the right thing to
do
and cabinet has agreed that the date of
transfer will be the first of october
2020
but there are many costs of doing this
taken together with the covered
estimated costs the hra's a budget gap
of 1.4 million
there are substantial one-off costs
relating to project management and i.t
there are also costs associated with
fixing the problems we inherited
from e-scan housing many of the reasons
for the decision to bring it in-house
were related to tenant health and safety
concerns around such issues as fire
safety and gas safety
our tower blocks require a huge amount
of investment coupled with the cost of
creating the new tenant and leaseholder
service the hra's finances
are taking a hit the report shows that
over the long term the hra can recover
although some of the warnings regarding
uncertainty that affect the general fund
also affects the hra and move the
recommendations
thank you very much new castle yes do
you have a second to there
second to please our second dude yeah
cancer album
council alvin again well done thank you
very much uh does anybody wish to debate
this discuss this matter
i call upon any counsellor now to step
forward
i'm not picking up anybody in the chat
column
so just to remind everybody the
recommendations of
this report council agree the following
number one the hra budget monitoring is
noted
number two that the revised hra budget
estimates for 2020
21 are approved thirdly that the revised
housing revenue account capital programs
attach annex 1 for 2024 are approved
fourthly the section 151 officers
assurance statement
as set out in section 10 of this report
is noted
fifthly note the 2019-2020 hra
provisional outcome position
and capital programs out turn as
attended annex
ii therefore turn to the monitoring
officer once again for recorded flows
thank you very much chairman councillor
alban
four now four
that's the ashby four
[Music]
four ounces of campbell
four councillor coleman cook
four that's a christendom
four that's a curry four
four that's a farance
four that's a fellows
four has a game four
that's a ghana four that's a green
that's a gregory four has a heart
oh he has a hopkinson
four that's a huxley four
counts are keen for
councillor patmore
thank you catholic for thank you
councillor linda piper
four thank you councillor stuart piper
four councillor pew
he's left a meeting okay that's a rat
again
that's a rough four
counts of rogers four
okay council of david saunders four
councillor maeve saunders four
council of savage four
counts for scoby four that's a scott
four that's a shrub four
that's a taylor four that's a tomlinson
a four that's a towning
four that's a wing
four that's the right
four that's the eights
four that's unanimous jim
thank you very much indeed monitor
monitoring officer uh
that concludes that item there for
agenda item
13 the report regarding urgent actions
under council procedure rule 28
now monitoring officer would you like to
um bring forward this
yes jim i'm happy to do so under a
constitution uh there's provision for
officers to take
urgent items um regular matters
between meetings and whether actually
urgent items are carried out
there's also an obligation to report
them back to council the cancer council
is aware of them
so the report here is is for members to
note
the first item relates to the ceiling of
documents
members will understand that under our
constitution the ceiling of documents is
carried out by a single member
and a single officer and
um if i the purpose of that is to um
it's not to check that whether lock is
accurate or to approve its contents
it's minute to attest that the council
has
has um affixed its common seal to that
document it's a procedural
rule now um obviously
take your minds back to the pandemic
when um when it started when the
lockdown came
when residents were only allowed to
leave their houses to shop for basic
amenities
whether only one form of exercise per
day where work travel was only only
can be carried out when absolutely
necessary and only if you can't work
from home
and that gatherings more than two people
was prohibited
so there was a concern that actually we
wouldn't be able to see it
wouldn't be able to seal documents for a
number of reasons one is that
um because of the lockdown restrictions
which stopped people
leaving home without reasonable excuse
and to minimize the risk of
transmission of the virus and
particularly to vulnerable shelter
people we
thought that the pool of people who
could actually see all the documents was
gonna be drastically reduced
also um you know one time
the staff were here um all week and
therefore
during that week you'd have 37 hours
when that ever could do any sealing
but actually with staff not being in the
building
then that time was limited a lot so not
only were the was the pool going to be
limited but also the time of
availability was also limited it had to
be a particular hour particularly when
ceiling took place
so given that given that that
restriction and the need to um
enable the council to continue to
complete contracts agreements
tree preservation orders um property
transactions statutory notices etc
um action was taken to actually widen
the pool of people who could seal
dawkins to increase it to two officers
being able to seal documents
and that was done and this is absolutely
absolutely made clear this is a
temporary measure
to cover the um the the issue caused by
the pandemic
so it will continue in place until until
we get closer to
normality when clearly we will have that
wider pool available
and there'll be wider hours available
for that to happen
so that that's the first item the second
item related to the um
business and planning act 2020 which
came into force in
in very short order it's about um
licensing of tables and chairs on the
highway
again there's no power to put a report
together to bring it to members
to explain how the delegation will work
in the act and how to actually implement
the terms of that
so again urgent action would say was
taken to
um delegate to all officers the
functions relating to
um the processing and determination of
applications for pavement
outdoor seating licenses to agree a fee
and also to give to the licensing
subcommittee licensing board
the function of hearing and deciding
appeals so there's two urgent items
they're brought to brought to this
council now not for approval
but to know those actions were taken and
the grounds for that action
thank you very much indeed monitoring
officer and of course that is the real
issue here this is a recommendation to
note the report
and and that only ah i'm therefore
prepared to um uh propose this and i
look to the vice chairman to second
vice chairman are you there yeah i
second that mr chairman
thank you very much indeed i do have two
speakers wish to speak councillor
tomlinson would you like to come in at
this point
thank you chair um i i made i've made it
quite clear my
concern originally
regarding the signature situation
because i know tim knows that i'm one of
the members that have been coming in
never had a problem
when i read the report earlier um
okay i had the impression which i don't
think i'm alone that it was
something which was continuous and
i felt that you know i remember whoever
that might be
should look at a document
and sign it as it has been done for
years
but i do know today
to him that you've tried to get me and
not ignoring you
i've had a crazy day but i the chairman
um
savage caught up with me during the
afternoon and explained exactly what
you've just explained that it is a
temporary
measure and obviously we are
all fed up with this covid um uh
but i do understand that and i do take
the point and i
i think yourself and other members
who are with us remember we had this
situation three years ago at standards
but i guess i'm quite happy with your
report tonight and thank you
thank you very much indeed councillor
tomlinson well said uh council piper i
have you next
thank you chairman mr house thank you i
think you've already answered this
if not totally then mostly in part i
mean the important thing in paragraph
2.4
was the sentiment that the attesting the
seal
is not to agree the content or the form
of the document but simply to show the
seal has been properly affixed
um i think that statement should allay
any concerns people might have
um i'm imagining there there therefore
if we're alone in kent
in operating it the way we have been is
there an intention to
leave it the way you now currently have
it or will you run it through
constitutional review standards and so
on to actually bring
our constitution more in line with
others
thank you chairman thank you very much
for piper monitoring officer um have you
got a response for that
i have yeah so as you say you're right
it's a temporary measure
and no no it won't continue forever with
that report going back i know the um
the constitutional review working party
did approve
this change but it was a standard
committee that opposed that so i think
it would have to come back
uh perhaps perhaps given the the length
of time that's passed since then
to review it again so so it's not
something i'll do um as a right
any permanent change we'll come back to
the constitution review working party
and then to standards and then after
that to the council
thank you very much indeed montrose sir
now i don't have anybody else wish to
speak just to remind members the
recommendation
council notes the urgent actions taken
under rule 28 of the council procedural
rules
um and that therefore if i hear no more
i think we can take that forward as
noted
thank you very much indeed members
uh i move the recommendation be agreed
and i presume that's all
fair fair and square with everybody
right moving on to
agenda all right so where am i
no i seem to have lost some my paperwork
here
agenda item 14 appointment of
independent members of the standard
committee
i recommended these amendments be agreed
uh would the vice chairman please second
on second note mr chairman
and the recommendation of course being
that mr lee welbrook and mr peter renzo
are appointed as independent members of
the stands committee
for a term expiring at the annual
meeting of the council
in 2023 uh i take it that no council has
any objections to this
thank you very much moving on to agenda
item 15
changes to committees panels and boards
and political balance
proportionality i call upon the leader
to make a proposal in respect of the
options outlined
in the report that we've all received
and had the opportunity to look at
leader um thank you thank you councillor
savage um the labour group would like to
support option one
so i propose option one which would
reduce the
labor group on planning from five to
four and increase the conservative group
to seven i believe
is there a sector for that
got a second of that please counselor
campbell council campbell thank you very
much indeed
all right does any member wish to
propose an alternative option
i don't think we do do we
therefore do members agree agreed
yes
yes thank you so much excellent thank
you
right moving on to agenda item 18
uh nomination of members to serve on
committees
not gender writing we're talking about
is the gender item 16.
nomination of members for serving
committees crew leaders may
to take this opportunity to advise of
changes of their nominations to
committees panels and boards remainder
of the 2020-21 uh year
council everett do you wish to advise
any nominational changes
um well i think we need to delete a
member from planning um
council savage i've got to admit that i
don't have this item on the public
agenda i'm not quite sure why
we've got an item which isn't on the
council website because i'm using the
council website to look at it
because it's certainly not a conf not a
confidential item
and i believe that the labor group is
proposing to take counsellor pat moore
off of planning
i'm sure somebody will correct me if i'm
wrong on that i think in actual fact
this is all
part of um a general item of 15
and i've assumed it has a separate um
number it doesn't it's within a gender
item 15.
so we're talking about uh the
relinquishment of one
of the planning councillors from your
side here
yes i think i think councillor pat moore
has kindly volunteered to
to to fall by the wayside on in this
occasion
and we're grateful to him okay lovely
thank you very much any castle everett
uh castle game
uh yes uh we would like to put uh
councillor ratigan on to planning
thank you very much indeed and of course
i presume councillor ratigan is
delighted with the opportunity yes sir
councillor piper that's reverend pipe
did you wish to advise of any
nominational changes
thank you chairman no changes thank you
very much councillor roper do you wish
to advise of any nominational change
actually it should be councillor
ghana here shouldn't it yes councillor
ghana what are we
we have no changes no changes
thank you very much indeed right members
thank you very much indeed for your time
this evening that includes the business
for this meeting of the council uh it
has been a
little bit longer than i thought it
would be but nevertheless i think we've
got everything done i think everyone had
an
opportunity to comment as they wished i
think we've had a very good meeting
thank you very much indeed see you all
if not
before in october good night